quantos de vocês aqui presentes quando
eram pequeninos tinha um sonho
o corpo em uma missão de criar uma
escola uma vida normal trabalhar e
encontra uma máquina igualzinho a
máquina com esta máquina ea capacidade
de encontrar mais pessoas incríveis
palavras muito complexa cirurgia e nada
nada
a capacidade de utilizar a tecnologia
para poder das pessoas que estavam no
laboratório e um empate
o que falar convosco então criar uma
ressonância emocional do que estou a
sentir em criar e produzir 2008 aumentou
a criar e produzir anda mil
não será isto o início da bateria com
esta tecnologia
isso é possível com a tecnologia nós já
conseguimos medir as intenções das
pessoas e com essa tecnologia é quando a
energia começa
joga
nós conseguimos saber que o coração
estava a pensar em tempo real
temos desvendado cinemas do cérebro
passamos por três fases a primeira é
avaliar o que comemorar
se está a pensar usamos uma técnica
chamada eo programa quantitativo que nos
diz horácio está a pensar esquerda não é
pensamento de esquerda o pensamento de
direita é pensar que era o governo que
vem para a esquerda ou mover o caminho
para a direita sempre que isso acontece
a zona morta esquerda fica mais ativa e
nós conseguimos fazer isso fica mais
ativa
o segundo passo temos que treinar
horácio treinador há seis anos uma
técnica chamada neurofeedback em coração
recebe um reforço positivo
sempre que consegue isolar o pensamento
de esquerda quer dizer sendo conseguimos
identificar uma assinatura eletrônica
fisiológica e um padrão daqui é o
pensamento assim sem coração não
consegue isolar algumas bolas e um som
que param e ao sabe conseguiu fechar e
isolar esse pensamento
horácio ao aparelho que nós queremos
coroar esse controlo
nesse caso o próprio avatar do horácio
pra mim é grande
a tecnologia é um ser humano comum já
não precisa mais um vereador para
comunicar mais um corpo já não precisa
mais um instrumento para mostrar às
pessoas um homem e máquina e simbiose
com estas máquinas no crescimento
contínuo em troca de informação e
melhorá los já que culturalmente
bastante o próximo passo agora é a
tecnologia ainda melhor
o objetivo máximo de um artista
comunicar às pessoas
o escritor de interiores já não precisam
mais usar a mão das suas intenções do
futuro mais uma vez gravámos assinaturas
eletrofisiológicas de cada frase que
queria escrever ou dizer que eu gostava
pensar nessas frases que elas eram
projetadas no cubo
infelizmente essa tecnologia já existe
qualquer pessoa cada um de vós pode
comprar essas interfaces cérebro
computador e utilizar em sua casa para
controlar a temperatura da casa a luz ou
até para jogar um jogo de computador já
existem clínicas de otimização de
performance onde fazem treinos de
melhoria com a comitiva treinadas
convidados e foi o primeiro tetraplégico
é conseguir olímpico
ao fazer um treino em que baixava o
ritmo cerebral conseguir atingir com
mais eficácia
imaginem essa tecnologia aplicada à arte
performances aplicada nova em moda pode
desenvolver roupa mórfica muda de cor ou
fugir à emoção das pessoas que vão usar
a roupa
imagine a tecnologia numa nova área
emergente chamado marketing interativo
do mar com a relação das pessoas com o
produto é ver como é que a pessoa tá
havia gir ao interagir com o mesmo
produto
a mensagem do computador para poder
comunicar com o exterior
há dois dias numa entrevista sobre seu
projeto espacial
juntamente como o facebook
no futuro pode vir a ser um super herói